the tally of ballots will continue here
in clark county and across the state of
nevada
until all are counted so at last check
there are still
a thousands though that do need to be
checked sasha loftis is live tonight
with more on
where the county stands as of right now
sasha
[Music]
denise and brian we still have a ways to
go both here in clark county and all
across nevada
officials say they have about 125
thousand ballots left to count
90 percent of those are here locally
former vice president joe biden's lead
is
widening in our state to just under 23
000 at the last update today
clark county registrar joe gloria said
today that about 8 thousand ballots were
verified
with about 115 000 to go again that
happened today
many voters were actually called down to
election headquarters earlier this
evening
to correct ballot errors or verify
signatures
this all to make sure their voice was
heard
because of course my vote needs to be
heard be counted
as well as my voice needs to be heard
and this is the place to do it and i'm
making sure
once i got down here they weren't
letting anyone in so
i wasn't leaving until i found heard the
final word that no one was coming in
and so they came and said you're the
last person in line so i'm making sure i
am not moving
until my vote is heard
[Music]
now registrar joe gloria did say his
team mistakenly reported
51 thousand ballots were counted
yesterday the actual number was in the
30 thousand range
now clark county will provide updates
about twice a day
to the public regarding these ballot
counts that is set to continue
through the weekend now you mentioned
the protests that happened out here
there was security
did remain peaceful but north las vegas
police and security guards were here
all through the night to make sure
things stayed that way reporting live in
north las vegas sasha loftis
8 news now